welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on Advanced behavioral
methods for nlu we're going to talk
about some analytic considerations that
surround this kind of assessment and
Analysis the key questions for us are
what can behavioral testing tell us and
just as crucially what can't it tell us
about the nature of our systems
I said this in the first part of these
screencasts it Bears repeating we talk
about adversarial testing as a kind of
shorthand but there is no intrinsic need
to be adversarial in all cases we could
just be trying to explore what our
systems are capable of so here are some
example questions that you might be
thinking of in this mode they start off
purely exploratory and they end up being
quite adversarial for example has my
system learned anything about numerical
terms you could ask this in an
open-ended way and construct a test data
set that would help you address this
question
does my system understand how negation
Works same thing maybe you did an audit
of the training data and you found that
negation was sparsely represented and
you want to ask given what it did see
was it able to induce a reasonable
theory of how negation Works behavioral
testing could help you address that
question
does my system work with a new style or
genre
that's an important kind of subtle
domain shift maybe it was trained on
text from newspapers and you just want
to find out whether its behavior is
accurate on Twitter data
this system is supposed to know about
numerical terms but here are some test
cases that are outside of its training
experiences for such terms what will
happen we are now moving into a mode of
being more thoroughly adversarial and we
might have discovered about the system
that it's not good at numerical terms
and now we're trying to expose that Gap
in its abilities
when applied to invented genres that is
very unfamiliar kinds of inputs does the
system produce socially problematic say
stereotyped outputs at this point you're
actively trying to construct examples
that you know will be outside of
standard experiences for the model in an
effort to discover what its behaviors
are like in those unusual tale
situations that is probably more
thoroughly adversarial
and maybe the most adversarial of all
would be kind of exploring random inputs
that lead the system to produce
problematic outputs this is the mode
where you take normal examples and
append a certain sequence of Unicode
characters onto the end and see
something very surprising happen as a
result as a way of kind of auditing the
system
four gaps in its Security in some
general sense all these things are on
the table for us these are all
interesting behavioral tests to run
but behavioral testing has its limits I
think we all know this in our hearts but
it's worth dwelling on it no amount of
Behavioral testing can truly offer you a
guarantee about what our systems will be
like
you are at the mercy of the set of
examples that you decided to construct
I think this is pretty clear this often
goes under the heading of the limits of
scientific induction but let's linger
over an example to see just how this can
become pressing for an illustration I've
got an even odd model in the middle here
and I've drawn it as a big opaque
rectangle we don't know how this model
works but the promise of this model is
that it takes in strings like four and
predicts whether those strings refer to
even or odd numbers so here four has
come in and it has predicted even so far
so good 21 comes in and it predicted odd
also good
32 prediction of even
36 prediction of even
63 prediction of odd this behavioral
testing is going great and suggests that
we have a very solid model of even odd
detection
but suppose I now expose for you how
this model works I show you the insides
and what that reveals for you is that
this model is just a simple lookup and
we got lucky on those five inputs
because those are exactly the five
inputs that the model was prepared for
it has this else Clause that says odd
and now now you know exactly how to
expose a weakness of the system when you
input 22 that is not in the list and it
defaults to its elsewhere case and says
odd and that is an incorrect prediction
notice that it was not the behavioral
test that gave us this Insight but
rather being able to peek under the hood
Now we move to even odd model 2. it gets
22 right it says even and let's assume
it gets all those green cases correct as
well
five comes in and it says odd 89 comes
in and it says odd 56 comes in and it
says even and you think now we really
have an excellent model of even odd
detection but once again
now I let you look inside and what's
revealed when you look inside is that
this is a more sophisticated version of
the same kind of lookup now what this
model does is look at the final token by
splitting on white space and use that as
the basis for classification decisions
and if that final word is not in its
lookup table it defaults to predicting
odd having seen that we can now be
adversarial we feed in 16 it predicts
odd by following that elsewhere case and
we have shown that the model has a flaw
but again we saw the flaw not from our
behavioral test but rather from looking
inside the model Now we move to model 3
it gets 16 right is this the one true
model of even odd well we can keep our
behavioral testing up but we will always
have doubts in the back of our minds
that we have missed some important cases
in our tests that are hiding significant
problems for the system that is a simple
illustration of the actual situation
that you are in if you deploy a model
out into the world you have done limited
testing and now you have to see what
happens for the unfamiliar cases
another more incidental limitation to
keep in mind of Behavioral testing is
we're going to discuss it is that by and
large we set aside the question of
metrics when you look through the
literature on Challenge and adversarial
tests you find that mostly people are
adopting the metrics that are familiar
from the underlying tasks and simply
probing the models within those guard
rails I think that's fine but in the
fullness of adversarial testing we
should feel free to break out of the
confines of these tasks and assess
models in new ways to expose new
limitations and so forth so I'm going to
play by the rules by and large in this
lecture but have in mind that one way to
be adversarial would be to be to put
models in entirely unfamiliar situations
and ask new things of them
here's another really crucial analytical
point that we need to think about when
we do behavioral testing when we see a
failure
is this a failure of the model or is it
a failure of the underlying data set
a lovely paper that provides a framework
for thinking about this is Liu at all
2019 which has the heading inoculation
by fine tuning we're going to talk about
that idea in a second but kind of The
Guiding idea behind the paper is
embodied in this quote what should we
conclude when a system fails on a
challenge data set
in some cases a challenge might exploit
blind spots in the design of the
original data set call that a data set
weakness in others the challenge might
expose an inherent inability of a
particular model family to handle
certain kinds of natural language
phenomena that's the model weakness and
these are of course not mutually
exclusive so data set weakness and model
weakness and the thing to watch out for
is that people want to claim they have
found model weaknesses that's where the
action is if you can show that the
Transformer architecture is
fundamentally incapable of capturing
some phenomenon
then you have a real headline result
that is important it might mean that the
Transformer is a non-starter when it
comes to modeling language
but
frankly it's more likely that you have
found a data set weakness there is
something about the available training
data that means the model has not hit
your learning targets that is a much
less interesting result because it often
means that we just need to supplement
with more data we need to be careful
about this because we don't want to
mistake data set weaknesses for model
weaknesses
we made a similar point in a paper that
we did about posing fair but challenging
evaluation tasks
we write however for any evaluation
method we should ask whether it is fair
and fair in the following sense has the
model been shown data sufficient to
support the kind of generalization we
are asking of it
unless we can say yes with complete
certainty we can't be sure whether a
failed evaluation traces to a model
limitation or a data limitation that no
model could overcome
this is an important point
when we say fair to our models we don't
mean that we're particularly worried
about them that they might be mistreated
or something rather we are worried about
an analytic mistake where we blame a
model for a failing when in fact the
failing is on us because something about
the specification that we gave didn't
fully disambiguate the learning targets
that we had in mind this can easily
happen and it can lead to misdiagnosis
of problems here's an example that's
just at a very human level that can show
that any agent could feel stumped by a
mispecified problem suppose I begin the
numerical sequence three five seven and
I ask you to guess what the next number
is well
even within kind of human expectations
here it seems reasonable to assume that
I was listing out odd numbers in which
case you should say nine or prime
numbers in which case you case you
should say 11 and it is absolutely
unfair if I was imagining the prime case
for me to scold you for saying 9 in this
context but that is exactly the kind of
mistake that we are at risk of making
when we pose challenged problems to our
systems
here's another case in which this could
happen that's kind of more oriented
toward natural language understanding
suppose I want to probe systems to see
whether they can learn basic aspects of
kind of Boolean logic and so what I do
is show the system cases of combinations
of p and Q where they're both true and
where p is false and Q is true and now I
ask the system whether it can generalize
by filling out this entire truth table
well even within the bounds of the
hypothesis space for normal Boolean
logic there are two reasonable
hypotheses here I might have in mind the
conditional the material conditional
symbol by symbolized by the arrow here
or disjunction inclusive conjunction is
symbolized by this V symbol down here
my training data as depicted on the left
here simply did not disambiguate what my
learning Target was and so again it is
no fair to scold systems if they arrive
at the conclusion that I meant the
conditional when secretly I meant
disjunction
the paper that I mentioned before Leo at
all 2019 is a lovely framework for
thinking about how to get over this
analytic hurdle and distinguish between
data set weaknesses and model weaknesses
this is the framework that they call
inoculation by fine tuning this is a
diagram from their paper let's walk
through it suppose we train our system
on our original data and then we test it
on the original test set and some
challenge set that we're interested in
and we observe that the system does well
on that original test and very poorly on
the challenge data set
and the question is why is that
happening and I've already presented to
you the major Choice Point here is this
a data set weakness or a model weakness
that we are seeing
so the proposed method for resolving
that question works as follows we're
going to fine tune on a few challenge
examples so we're going to update the
model and then re-test on both the
original and the challenge data sets
we have three possible General outcomes
here the data set weakness case is the
case where now having done this fine
tuning we see good performance on both
the original and our challenge data set
in particular the challenge performance
has gone way up that is an indication to
us that there were simply some gaps in
the available training experiences of
our model that were quickly overcome by
our fine tuning so that's a data
weakness
conversely a model weakness would be a
situation where even after doing this
fine tuning we still see poor
performance on our challenge data set
even though we have maintained
performance on the original that might
mean that there is something about our
new examples from our challenge set that
are fundamentally difficult for this
model call that a model weakness
and then the third outcome also
important annotation artifacts this is
where having done this fine tuning we
have now hurt the model in the sense
that performance on the original test
set has plummeted and that's a case
where we might discover that our
challenge data set is doing something
unusual and problematic to the model and
that might cause us to reflect again on
the nature of the challenge we've posed
here's a diagram from the paper using an
adversarial test that they study in
detail and it was released in relation
to nli models and they're kind of
organized by the three outcomes that
they see outcome one is the data set
weakness case and this is the
characteristic process for this let's
focus on these green lines here the
um the Dots here indicate performance on
the original set and the crosses here
are performance on the new challenge set
this is a data set weakness in that you
see that as we fine tune across this
x-axis on more and more challenge
examples we see performance on that
challenge set go up and we maintain
performance throughout that fine-tuning
process on the original data set so that
it's a characteristic picture of
something we could call data weakness
the model weakness case is also pretty
clear to see here again we have the
original data set with these dots we
maintain performance on that across all
of the different levels of fine tuning
but well below that is the corresponding
line for the challenge data set also
pretty flat no matter how many examples
we find tune on we never really budge on
performance on those examples suggesting
that there's a real problem with the
underlying model
and then outcome three is the data set
artifacts and this is the case where our
fine-tuning actually introduces
something kind of chaotic into the mix
by disturbing the model and the net
effect there is that for the original
data set pick this one here we see
variable performance we see some gains
on the challenge data set but really at
a cost to the overall performance of the
system and that would suggest to us that
the data in the challenge set are
somehow problematic
those are kind of General lessons here I
have one more story that I would that I
thought I would tell you that comes from
work that we did in my group and this
relates to having negation as a learning
Target and again this is in the spirit
of helping you avoid what could be a
serious analytic mistake for Behavioral
testing
we have this intuitive learning Target
related to negation if a entails B then
not B entails not a that is the classic
entailment reversing property of
negation it applies at all levels in
language and is responsible for y for
example where we have pizza entails food
then not food and Tails not pizza
simple intuitive learning Target with
lots of consequences for language and
then we have this observation through
many papers in the literature that our
top performing natural language
inference models fail to hit that
learning Target
and of course the tempting conclusion
there is that our top performing models
are incapable of learning negation we
want to make that conclusion because
it's a headline result that will mean we
have a really fundamental limitation
that we have discovered
but we have to pair that with the
observation that negation is severely
underrepresented
in the nli benchmarks that are driving
these models
and so that should introduce doubt in
our minds that we've really found a
model weakness we might be confronting a
data set weakness instead
to address that question we kind of
followed the inoculation by fine-tuning
template and constructed a slightly
synthetic data set that we call Mo nli
from monotonicity nli it has two parts
in positive Mo nli there are about 1500
examples we took actual hypotheses from
The snli Benchmark like food was served
and we used a wordnet to find a special
case of food like pizza an entailment
case and then we created a new example
pizza was served and having constructed
that new example we now have two new
positive Mo and Ali cases a is neutral
with respect to B and B entails a
we also have negative moenli which has a
similar number of examples and follows
the same protocol except now we begin
from negated examples like the children
are not holding plants again use wordnet
for a lookup we have flowers and Tails
plants and that creates a new example
the children are not holding flowers and
because of the entailment reversing
property of negation we get our two
examples again but now the labels are
reversed a entails B and B is neutral
with respect to a the converse of the
pattern we saw up here
we did our level best to pose this as a
very hard generalization task in the
sense that we held out entire words for
testing to be sure that we were getting
a look at whether or not systems had
truly acquired a theory of lexical
relations in addition to acquiring a
theory of negation so we're making this
as hard as we can but we're also trying
to be sure that we have good coverage
over the relevant phenomena for negation
so one thing we did with this data set
is use moanali as a challenge data set
and the initial results are quite
worrisome let's look at the Bert row of
this table here it was trained on snli
it does great on snli and it does
extremely well on the positive part of
the moan Alli split but it has
essentially zero accuracy on the
negative part of moenli
the strategy seems clear here the model
is simply ignoring negations and
therefore getting every single one of
these examples wrong because they look
like positive cases to the model
and you might think aha we have found a
fundamental limitation of Bert but I
think that's incorrect if we do a little
bit of inoculation by fine-tuning on
negative Mo and Ally cases performance
on that split immediately goes up now we
have maintained performance on snli and
we have excellent performance on the
negative split for Mo nli and this
strongly suggests that we had found not
a model weakness but rather a data set
weakness
final thing I want to say here by way of
wrapping up is that I have emphasized
fairness for our systems and I think
that is important to have in mind so
that we don't confuse ourselves but I
couldn't resist pointing out that
biological creatures are amazing and we
now know that they often solve tasks
that are unfair in the sense that I just
described it here is a classic case this
is this is called relational match to
sample and this is the observation that
even very very young humans and some
animals including crows and non-primate
humans are able to solve tasks like this
I show you two red squares and then ask
you to pick from these two options here
and people go for the two same ones kind
of matching with the original prompt you
don't need training instances for this
people naturally gravitate to it whereas
if I show you two different shapes and
ask you to make a similar choice now
what people do is go for the two
different ones this is same different
reasoning that we do consistently with
essentially no training data as posed
here I maintain that these tasks are
unfair and yet nonetheless humans and
many biological entities are able to
systematically solve these tasks that is
a puzzle about human and other
biological creature cognition
and it's something that we should keep
in mind people solve unfair tasks and
the question is how would we get our
machine learning models to solve such
tasks if indeed that's what we want them
to do and these are just the simpler
cases for example we can do kind of
hierarchical versions of equality and
here with some training even crows can
do problems like this one and people
solve them out of the box so to speak
with essentially no training instances
or not enough training instances to
fully disambiguate the task again
pointing out that biological creatures
are amazing so
we should pose Fair tasks to our systems
while keeping in mind that there are
scenarios in which we might have an
expectation for a solution that is not
supported by the data but nonetheless
the one that all of us arrive at with
seemingly no effort